foreign
welcome back time for the Press preview
then it's our first look at what is on
the frontal Friday's papers and it's
time to check out those headlines with a
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
and the broadcaster and political
commentator Salma Shah they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight a
very good evening uh to you rather
belatedly let's take a look then at some
of those front pages shall we starting
with the Metro they need your help now
reads the front pages they look at the
need for Aid in Syria and turkey
following the recent earthquake
pressures are on the treasury over tax
according to the front of the Daily Mail
as AstraZeneca snubs the UK to build a
plant in Ireland because of corporate
taxes
well the money-saving expert Martin
Lewis is on the front of the Daily
Mirror as he condemns raising the cap on
energy bills saying it would be a
national Act of harm
and greedy Banks blasted over savings
rates reads the front of the Daily
Express
blessings for same-sex couples given CV
approval raise the front of the Guardian
as they look at what is being called a
profound shift in the church's stance on
homosexuality and the front of the eye
investigates claims that untreated
sewage is being discharged into the
river calm by Thames at water and
Exclusive by them is the Ft looking at
restructuring within Walt Disney that
will see 7 000 jobs axed
and the front of the Daily Star has the
headline vote chuckle as one of the
chuckle Brothers announces a campaign to
get Britain laughing again don't we need
that and a reminder that by scanning the
QR code you'll see on screen throughout
the program you can check out all of the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them and to
discuss them Steve Richards and Selma
sure very good to see this evening so
lots to get through and let's start with
the desperate desperate situation Salma
in turkey and Syria as well the front of
the Metro has that rescuer carrying the
Little Boy in the Striped jumper and
they're asking us to uh give what we can
in order to help that rescue effort
yes and it's it's one of those things
that we are looking at that is
absolutely heart rendering because this
is a full-blown humanitarian crisis and
we're going to see a lot of appeals and
a lot of people who are going to try and
fundraise I think one of the interesting
things about this is especially the
relief effort in Syria because of course
diplomatic relations with the Syrian
government are not what they should be
and we will have heard the foreign
secretary today in Rome talking about
liaising with the uh opposition in Syria
and this I think will at some point sort
of stymie and hamper some of those
relief efforts because of the difficult
political situation that exists in these
countries but as you can see these
pictures of children that are being
um helped you know after days under the
rubble and this race to try and find
survivors uh continue so there is
definitely an emergency and a panic uh
with this relief effort at present which
is implicated by several issues yes
Steve they call it the golden period or
the golden window don't they and it is
coming to an end and of course it's
probably shorter than it would have been
if the earthquake had happened in the
summer simply because it's so cold and
you've got this awful situation where
people are calling out for help but the
help isn't there and they're dying of of
of of the coals and starvation
yeah it's unbearable and I can't face
frankly watching the uh pictures or
reading too much about it you know in
programs like this and many others we
analyze how things happen in politics
and economics and all the other dramas
and there's a dispute about why and how
things happen here there's a natural
disaster it's horrific
um and and you're almost kind of
speechless beyond the issues that salmon
has brilliantly summarized about the
challenges of making this rescue effort
as effective as possible and in a way
when you see these pictures and I just
glance at them fleetingly because
they're unbearable you hope somehow
rather some of the barrier shout outline
could be transcended in this case
because you've just conjured up an
absolute nightmare of people screaming
for help and the help not being there
and um yeah I mean there's not much more
we can say Beyond let's hope the rescue
teams do get through and effective away
as possible but but the origins are you
know what can we say it's a natural
disaster and it's a form of hell yeah
inside the Metro as well every penny
counts uh Salma interestingly uh 1966
was the first ever disasters and
emergency committee appeal and that was
for an earthquake in Turkey all those
years ago and here we are seeing another
appeal with the likes of Daniel Craig
also members of the royal family all uh
asking for help but of course it's
difficult for people isn't it with a
cost of living crisis
I think this is absolutely a critical
factor for those people who are usually
incredibly uh generous with what they do
but I I think that um I mean this is
this is probably slightly me being over
patriotic but I think the British are
very high up there on the list of people
who are always willing to give
and I think it's it's different that
these campaign that people who have a
platform like the royal family like
celebrities like uh Daniel Craig are
there sort of asking for that help
because as Steve rightly says it's a
humanitarian crisis this isn't the same
as kind of like political difficulties
this isn't a cause there is no blame
here this is about getting help to
people
urgently and immediately the challenge
as I say just to reiterate is always
about whether those structures are there
in order to help people
um you know the factor as you've just
rightly pointed out uh is you know the
weather the challenges that are faced
with emergency services in these
countries about whether they are robust
enough to deal with a an issue of this
magnitude and I think being able to also
look at some of those issues to how you
can ease the pain for those people who
don't necessarily have the
infrastructure in order to get people
out of this Rubble is going to be really
critical and as we go through that
relief effort yeah it really is it's the
same story on the front of the financial
times they also mentioned that un Convoy
of six trucks that's been able to get
from Turkey across the border into Syria
just the tip of the iceberg of course um
Steve let's move our attention to the
new Deputy conservative party chairman
Lee Anderson who said that he would
support reintroducing the death penalty
what did you make of this
yeah well I mean this route actually
comes up every now and again it's it's
got the headlines because he's just been
made Deputy chairman and no doubt with a
sort of slightly clunky but deliberate
attempt to Target the so-called red wall
seats with this kind of talk
um and it's got a lot of people very
worked up I wonder how far this will go
and take him and the arguments that he
espoused it's quite often in politics
you get kind of Maverick figures Rising
not to the very top or the sort of
cabinet Rank and so on but hovering
around that area they generate a lot of
headlights but don't last that long I
might be wrong with him but I doubt it
somehow yeah Salma
um the Prime Minister said today that's
not my view that's not the government's
view simple as that
yes and it this is one of those things
where it's going to continually cause
political issues because of the way that
Lee Anderson is potentially going to rub
up against the sort of status quo as it
is you know the death penalty in this
country is not going to change the
status of the death penalty in this
country is not going to change and I
think it will serve as a distraction to
have these kinds of headlines uh
whenever Lee Anderson decides that he
wants to make a statement and as Steve
rightly says it is that kind of Maverick
element but nonetheless you know Lee
Anderson was obviously chosen for a
reason to become the deputy party
chairman and it is the fact that he has
these red wall credentials I think the
prime minister is going to have to think
very hard about how you know Lee
Anderson is now deployed uh in the in
the widest sphere when he's thinking
about campaigning but these sort of
asides I think will provide number 10
with a number of headaches over the sort
of next 18 months before for general
election okay let's move on to a couple
of financial stories in the mail and the
mirror starting with the mail Steve when
will treasury get the message over tax
this is so interesting because you have
the Liz truss intervention and while she
herself was uh much ridiculed for her
return to the center of the political
stage the message about tax cuts even
after all that happened last September
and October when there was an attempt at
these tax cuts and just all hell broke
Loops well it's returned in the very
powerful uh Daily Mail it's been around
in the Daily Mail for some time and in
some of the other Tory newspapers and
amongst MPS beyond the immediate
Entourage who were around as trust and
what is so interesting is the immediate
context the build up to the March budget
uh the sense of the tour is well behind
in the opinion polls and although it
seems to me crazy to be raising the same
kind of agenda that trust had in
September and October there is a potency
within parts of the conservative party
for it just as Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor prepares for a budget where
he has been quite open in the past
anyway that at this point the tax
cutting agenda is not his okay uh
someone would get your thoughts on that
story uh in the next hour but just tell
us very quickly about the front of the
mirror what's Martin Lewis been saying
uh Martin Lewis is very annoyed at the
suggestion that the cap on energy
pricing is going to increase therefore
sort of taking certain people out of uh
this benefit that the government has
been giving in terms of subsidy and he
has been very robust on the front page
of the mirror saying that this would be
a real catastrophe for those families
and I think that this is going to be
something that continues but the
government position is very difficult
because they don't have a lot to play
with so um we'll see how this unfolds
over the the coming weeks
uh Steve your thoughts on this
yeah well again in a way it's the
counter isn't it that um while there is
this huge demand for tax cuts uh
obviously to continue and Martin Lewis
is right that um I think in some form or
another they will need to continue costs
money so at the same time you have these
two conflicting pressures on sunak and
hunt from the mail cut taxes cut taxes
from Martin Lewis increased spending uh
or borrowing to subsidize these still
very high energy bills
um now you know
can they do both and the answer usually
in these situations is no when money is
so tight uh so it's it's it's a really
Vivid juxtaposition of the pressures
they are under and the pressures become
much more intense when they are so far
behind in the polls what is the route
back can they risk uh people saying we
can't afford our bills again
um can they risk not tax cut not cutting
taxes when this shrill scream is out
there in parts of the part of the Tory
party it's it it it's a fascinating
backdrop to this March budget yeah it
really is isn't it it's going to be very
interesting a few weeks in the run-up to
that um and just to finish a story from
the eye this is uh completely different
to all the other front pages a bit of an
excuse Exclusive by the eye Salma um
Fogel Sharkey uh the singer has really
been campaigning hard on this
yes so this is a story that um hs2
development has basically resulted in
raw sewage from that being pumped into a
green belt River and this is I think a
real sort of um damaging thing for hs2
which is already under intense political
pressure because big infrastructure
projects are always under intense
political pressure and I think this is
going to prove to be another one of
those things that just adds more
arguments to those people who have
always thought that hs2 is a bad idea
but unfortunately the government has
committed the money uh things are
progressing so I don't think it will end
up sort of hurting the project long term
but I think it does create a lot of
cynicism around it continually yeah I
mean it's a very strong front page isn't
it Steve
yeah and it's deeply depressing I think
they also name uh Thames water as well
and it is somehow a kind of depressing
metaphor uh that this is going on uh
around quite a lot of Britain's coastal
areas and rivers and so on and it has to
be stopped it is utterly uh grotesque
um and whether it can be done with
regulation or whether these kind of
privatized monopolies with uh clearly
inadequate regulation as just an
unsustainable model
um I'm not sure not sure but it has to
stop
um and I think it will be one of the
quite early challenges if there is a new
labor government next year at some point
um as to whether this can be done
because we keep on hearing oh yeah don't
worry it's being sorted you know and so
on and yet every month or so you get
more examples of it happening and it's
terrible yeah we haven't got uh the
response from Thames water as we only
have the front pages of course but
fergal Sharkey says it's another
grotesque example of what the
environment agency calls regulation with
yet more damage being done to a
wonderful River picture there of the the
river con by uh Thames water there